[Musique]
un nouveau fait a ajouté au chapitre des
soucoupes volantes un cultivateur de
moringhem monsieur daniel you a été le
témoin stupéfait mais observateurs de la
présence d'un de ces engins que les
scientifiques appellent duterne de
compromettant d'objets volants non
identifiés
voici la déclaration que ce nouveau
témoin a bien voulu nous faire payer on
allait manger si mes beaux-parents et en
rentrant le soir on a abaissé sur la
route comme une boule rouge qui arrivait
sur nous l'arrivée sur la droite et dans
un virage nous a coupé la route et d'adp
est parti sur la gauche
alors on a dû freiner brusquement pour
le vitib parce qu'on ne pouvait pas
passer en dessous le tout le monde passe
et basse et après nous ont suivis comme
ça 12 13 100 m à 4 m de nous sur la
gauche vous avez nettement l'impression
d'avoir été observée par cet ange alors
un peu benêt qu'en matière de services
mais c'est bizarre qu'elle vient de se
passer pour notre voiture et quelle
forme avait-il en dessous c'était une
boule rouge est au dessus il y avait une
masse ne peut pas distinguer ce que
c'est parce qu on est ébloui basse rouge
à cette blouse rouge se paieront cela et
c'était comme un soleil c'était roméo
dessus peut pas d'excès père ont souvent
l'impression que c'était télécommandées
ou qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui pilotait
on peut dire qu'ils avaient quelques
dents contre certainement ce que je vous
dis havel et l'arbre et est passé en
deux alors certainement qui voyait clair
si tu doutes ou quoi
toujours est il que depuis cette
rencontre les vaches refusent leur
nourriture
les chiens sont fébriles y at il parmi
nous comme certains le prétendent des
présence d'un visite
[Musique]